elle a l'air d'être sorti de la chaîne
voici dix ans et pourtant elle vient de
naître
les jeunes regrettait la bonne vieille
deux pintes il fallait à baisser le prix
du bas de gamme alors citroën a décidé
de revenir sur ses pas et a fait du neuf
avec de l'ancien résultat la deux
chevaux s s comme spéciale est-ce aussi
comme simplifier certains diront comme
sommaire pour l'intérieur retour aussi
agent tubes mais monté sur glissières
retour aussi à un tableau de bord bien
connu et où charnières de portes
apparente rien à dire jusque là tout
cela respire la rusticité mais rempli
son office
un regret toutefois la suppression du
cendrier à l'extérieur même souci
d'économie tous les enjoliveurs ont
disparu et les phares ronds sont revenus
là non plus aucun reproche hélas la
troisième vitre latérale a elle aussi
disparue nous visibilité réduite
côté mécanique rien de changé le moteur
est celui de la deux chevaux 4 et 7
automobile au passé simple sera à vous
pour la somme tout de même assez élevé
de 11 1852 francs économique à l'usagé
c'est vrai accrocheuse
c'est vrai aussi la deux chevaux tient
la route parfois même elle la tient tout
si vos biceps ne sont pas assez
puissants pour maîtriser en virage un
volant épris d'indépendance
mais ce sont là des qualités et des
défauts bien connus comme d'ailleurs la
faculté de la dose
se transformer en véhicule tout terrain
et son freinage hésitant bref la deux
chevaux spécial c'est la continuité sans
le changement mais ce petit côté désuet
de la voiture ne manque pas de charme
les puristes en seront sans doute ravis
en tout cas chez citroën on l'espère
[Musique]